[Applause]
celebrations in abujan after months of
uncertainty these Ivory Coast soldiers
were facing decades in a prison in Mali
but a pardon from the country's military
government allowed them to return home
Ivory Coast Mali it's not the same thing
it was very hard I'm home now and I'm
very happy
he was arrested on his birthday but
today we're relieved we cried we fasted
we prayed and finally God has answered
us I'm in Joy words fail me
president Alison watra who's there to
greet them
the fate of the soldiers was at the
center of months of diplomatic wrangling
the incident created a rift between the
two countries but water made clear he
wants to put it behind them
I would like you to know that Ivory
Coast will continue to offer support to
all brother countries African and others
who need to evolve towards peace as I've
often said without peace there is
nothing important for a nation peace is
essential and you went to bring peace to
Mali and I strongly hope that this
brother country will find peace once
more the troops were arrested in July
they were accused of being mercenaries
and put on trial
Ivory Coast says they were part of a
United Nations peacekeeping Mission U.N
forces have been deployed to the region
for years as armed groups threatened
stability
but Mali has been increasingly isolated
since Colonel asimi goita seized power
in a military coup two years ago
the military government has missed
deadlines for organizing elections and
blocked U.N forces for investigating
alleged violations of human rights
but the return of the soldiers was
framed as a gesture of Goodwill to the
region a possible sign that Molly may be
ready to re-engage with the
International Community
Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera